how do you control rumors and gossip
within an organization that's pretty
easy you just you just talked about
being you know getting out there with
the truth and your propaganda arm to
outside your company it's no different
inside your company you've got to make
sure that people eat it's an interesting
that when you work we work with leaders
sometimes you see people that I why I
don't want to share this with my people
you know cuz I don't know what they
might think like there are they're
thinking yeah something that may be
totally not true they're not just
sitting there not thinking anything
because you're not sharing it with them
they're coming up to their own
conclusions which may be completely
false or opposite but like we say in the
in the Navy all the time you know
perception is reality that becomes
reality so you've got a you got a you
can defeat the gossip and rumors by
actually just sharing the truth be open
with people and and and and be in first
out there with a message so people get
an understanding and even when horrible
bad things go wrong extreme ownership
right if if you take ownership for that
and say hey listen this happened here's
what we're doing to fix it here's what
we're doing to turn things around it's
kind of the people people are not gonna
lose respect for you in the organization
they're actually gonna gain respect for
you as a result something we talk about
all the time so don't be afraid to do
that again just get the message out
there and and be transparent and talk to
folks if you don't tell people what's
going on they're gonna make up their own
ideas of what's going on and the thing
that I have to I have to we have to we
have to take this just a little bit
further right just a little bit further
because we talked about transparency
right and that war gets thrown around
all the time and of the idea that you're
just gonna you that the idea that you're
just gonna tell everyone exactly what's
going on and that sounds great and it's
like hey I'm a fully transparent leader
and I'm gonna tell you what's going on
but there's times where you actually
don't want to do that there's times
where you have to maneuver and you have
to be tactful and some of the things
that you might tell someone actually is
not the right thing to do now and I I'm
not saying we're gonna be dishonest with
our people I'm not saying that and I'm
saying that transparency is a great
thing but I mean just on a personal
level
if Leif's leaves up working for me and
he's not doing he's doing something
horrible is the best way to go about
that to fully true full transparency is
hey life you're doing horrible at this
is that the best way to do it in front
of out the entire in front of thing
right is that is that it's full
transparency right hey I'm fully
transparent okay everyone welcome to the
meeting today by the way I just wanted
to point out that life to missus numbers
again and he's a loser
that might be what I'm thinking that's
fully transparent hey guys just beat and
and you love this too right just being
transparent
Leif's an laysa loser he missed his
numbers again and you know what I'm
actually thinking about firing him just
in case anyone was wondering so that's
that's my getaway to close the business
Friday did I do a good job right so so
let's not get carried away
right you know what is the smart way
this smart ways to maneuver the smart
way is to say okay lace not doing what
he what he no wants to what he should be
doing if I go and accuse him of failing
what's his reaction gonna be how is it
so what I do instead instead I go I want
to take ownership of it and so instead I
said hey Lafe you know
hey he comes and come to come come I
laughs I want to talk to you bout a
couple things so he comes to my office
or not in a public place and now it's
hey Lafe hey man I noticed that you you
know you you missed your numbers and I'm
thinking that maybe I'm not giving you
the kind of support that you need
to get where you need to be is there
anything else that you need from me so
that you can win again inside sure I'm
thinking life you pathetic loser
you missed your numbers again right but
I'm not gonna do that so the full
transparency thing I get it and it makes
sense but we do have to consider the
tertiary and the secondary and tertiary
effects of the things that we say
especially as a leader you what you say
has a lot of impact as a leader and
sometimes I see leaders they make a
little off-the-cuff remark about
something you know oh that won't matter
oh oh okay so it doesn't matter or so so
this little thing you know
hey hey boss we wanted to get this this
task done by this date is it still
important ah doesn't matter okay so it
doesn't matter so what I was working on
for last month and a half doesn't matter
okay cool great if I was fully
transparent so just be careful use tact
use your brain yeah that's that's 100%
correct I think you know what I was
trying to explain in the first situation
is I mean I was having a conversation
with a leader that we work with who was
you know telling me that there was a key
leader in his team that didn't want to
share with any of his key leaders that
they you know they they're the he didn't
want to share with the key leaders that
they were they were haven't having some
issues and having some dire straits
wonder you know getting to a point where
they're wondering hey I don't know if
we're gonna make payroll you know a few
months from now if we don't turn these
things around but I don't want to share
that with them because I don't want him
to panic mmm and when I when I heard
that I was like what kind of panic are
they gonna have when they find out yeah
they can't make payroll but no one told
him of that and they thought everything
was great so the pen is gonna be a
hundred times worse yeah then and that's
that's the kind of transparency I'm
talking about we're like listen you need
to go and have a direct conversation to
say guys here's where we're at
yeah and that should be something to
help get them in year be like listen we
have got to we've got to hit these
numbers we've got to get things going
again we gotta turn performance around
or this is where we're gonna be next
quarter if we don't do that and I think
those that's the kind of thing I'm
talking about where you're not keeping
the secrets is it not helping you out
because by the way everyone knows the
numbers right so they know they already
probably know you're in dire straits and
they're thinking well I better find a
backup job and they're gonna leave and
now you're an even worse straight so
yeah absolutely you don't need to hide
information from from the team